This bike path is in the Netherlands.
It's called the Van Gogh-Roosegaarde Bicycle Path.
It is based on the "Starry Night" painting,...
...the one that we're all so very familiar with.
Have you ever seen this painting online?
I'm sure you have.
It's a one-kilometer long section of a route...
...that goes through the province where Van Gogh was born and raised.
So it's very near where he was brought up.
It is extremely bright.
So they're coated with special paint...
...and it grabs daylight almost like something that's glow-in-the-dark or solar-powered.
Right.
But this is kind of a cool thing.
There are also extra LEDs along the sides of, parts of the curves of the bike path.
So they help illuminate them when maybe it's overcast...
...and there's not enough energy to actually power these.
It's so beautiful...
...and this is a really great kind of example...
...of how technology can make the world just a prettier place.
What a fantastic and whimsical way of giving people a beautiful, well-lit bike path.